I get to concentrate on music now which
is what I've wanted to do for a really
long time and now I actually have to
what so yet all this is still just a
people section soy sauce that's just
like salt water that's for sushi but
you're oh my gosh sorry hey hmm is that
you da my name's Clyde
that's not food that's person yeah it's
okay she's super hungry that's why we're
here Chloe we met a girl uh she's coming
over something smell weird in here
where is it it's right in this area
somewhere I'm in it I'm close really
close oh okay
slowly introduce puppy to water it's a
surprise
you're swimming it turns on the swimming
in stinks doesn't it
are you ready for adventure I speak
Jorgen you big drawer gone let's touch
normals I can read your thoughts
I saw everything thousand past lives
your once Christina
Oh
what goes good with onions that grocery
store is such I go there all the time I
can't believe haven't seen you how are
you um how are you you think she's
coming oh hey hi you're here I'm here
I came okay I made dinner I'm we for you
for us um
you eat food I do indeed eat food but
thank you um good luck so do you live
close to the reservoir
yeah actually live right on the other
side really yeah because I feel like I
maybe actually have seen you I used to
walk around it a lot alone and now I
walk around with Chloe and we go a lot
slower but Affiliate goes by a lot
faster she's so cute she is really cute
Chloe you haven't touched your food
should I offer a bite of mine oh no no
no uh she has her own food dog food
puppy food Oh heavy food for puppies and
human food for humans yeah that works
baby food for babies yeah will you try
something with me
how often do you do a good name
floors are super clean that's why
they're so slippery have a good night oh
good night she kissed my mustache haha
oh oh man we did it we did good I'm so
glad we took baths